hey everybody I have a special
announcement to make um you may have
heard me say this on my ymh episode but
I am starting a new podcast it's going
to be right here on this YouTube channel
it's called the way back it drops
Thursday January 4th and it will be a
weekly pod every Thursday moving forward
after that all right um it's a Nostalgia
podcast it's a short one too it's a
quick kitter no more than 30 minute
episodes with some of your favorite
guest in comedy and podcast casting we
already have a ton of them recorded uh
I'm very excited to do this if you're a
big fan of the crab Feast if you're a
big fan of the honey do I know you're
going to be a big fan of this show um
it's just something I've always thought
about you know and the set is the back
seat of that old school station wagon
facing traffic looking that way all
right it's the way back cuz we're
sitting in the way back and we're
looking back on things and uh here's a
fun teaser just just to get you excited
about the idea check this out it's the
way back with Ryan sickler right here on
my YouTube channel every Thursday
beginning January
4th what would you say were like your
favorite parts of grow up we did a lot
of playing with fire 80s we were feral
kids you know we throw rocks and cars wh
brother grew some of the best pot in
Northern California we play another dri
game called dri and driveing it left the
crater it was danger all the time and
that's when I started popping
obviously there's some level of autism I
was like I'm just going to put the
artillery shells in the back seat wait
no
oh oh that's a nice little throwback
Good
[Music]
Times the Honeydew with ran
[Applause]
sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pant
Studios I'm Ryan sikler Ryan sikler and
Ryan sickler on all your social media
I'm kicking this episode off the same
way I kick off every episode by saying
thank you thank you for supporting the
show thank you for watching I don't care
if you you're new here or if you've been
here thank you for the support Please
Subscribe hit the Subscribe button it's
a free way to help the show and if you
got to have more then trust me check out
the patreon it's called the Honeydew
with y'all and it's this show with y'all
it's five bucks you're getting the
Honeydew a day early you're getting it
ad free no extra cost you get audio you
get video to the entire back catalog of
the wildest stories you've ever heard in
your life it's worth it cup of coffee to
try one time trust me on this all right
if you're looking for a new podcast to
listen to go check out my old podcast to
crab Feast I love it it's a look man
it's been done for almost five years and
it still has a cult following and the
library is going to do over a million
downloads this year that's what I'm
talking about so it's got everybody you
love and comedy on it check it out all
right now you guys know what we're doing
over here we're highlighting the low
lights I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers and I'm
very excited to have today's guest on
here for the first time ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome Mike ve welcome
to thanks for having me Ryan thank you
buddy it's good to have you here brother
long overdue actually no I appreciate it
I appreciate being on um well it's great
to have you here and before we get into
any of the stuff we're going to talk
about plug promote everything and
anything Mike veon please first of all
I'm at Comic mikev on all soci all
social media platforms at Comic mikev um
mik von.com for dates um I have a
podcast called Mike veon investigates on
gas digital you can get it on Apple
iTunes uh and my special is called the
attractives it's on YouTube right now
it's a great special thank you buddy
over a million views go check that one
out
um is that everything yeah that's
everything mik von.com for dates oh
that's say where can they get tickets
all right Mike von.com um it's good to
have you here I I really got to sit and
talk with you during your epic special
right and um I remember some of the
things we talked about but not
everything obviously
and again you showed up and I was like
you know I I thought you were you look
Bronx to me and you're like nah I'm
young down Ohio and I'm like huh what
you do not people get confused they go
are there in New York they go there's
Italians in Ohio and then I get
defensive I go who do you think built
this country huh who do you think built
it and they go all right calm down no
you calm down no you calm down I like to
go
right it's pretty that's why I like you
dude my whole family's Italian the only
one that wasn't was my dad's dad who's
sickler everyone else is D memo Deo and
everything is that everything's I love
Zer love you you talking about instantly
hey what's going on you want a couple
what do you mean what do you mean dude I
love that at my younger brother's
wedding my I have a twin brother we're
fraternal twins we're [__] just
finally had enough enough of each other
enough of the [__] like this wedding
was in Jamaica and he said I'm going to
put my credit card down and so good I'm
going to put my credit card down you can
pay me back and I was like yeah no
problem so I don't know what happened
but their car got
declined and his wife came up to him and
started to tell him he didn't let her
finish the whole story started to say
hey we put our charges and your
brother's charges on our card and our
card got declined so he's like what
he comes listen it's a hill he comes
marching up this Hillside of Jamaica
it's beautiful it's called roundhill
like they're like Paul McCartney stays
here and you know we have no business
being here you know I mean with our
[__] he's [__] Trucking up the
hill and it's it's guys we are still
close with from middle school and their
wives the wives are new to us the guys
from middle school they this you know
right he comes up he's like listen
[__] and whole Hillside can hear
this and I'm looking at I'm was just as
surprised as everybody else listen
[__] you put your godd damn [__]
on our car now you [__] everything up
and his wife's going Derek now he's
thinking she's trying to get him to Cal
down he said no and he's just going on
and he's like this is the last [__]
time we ever vacation together and I and
I'm just I'm being calm at first and I'm
just like this is the first time we've
ever vacation together and the last this
is it and he's going nuts and he's like
you stupid [__] and he's
screaming at a level CU it's but it's
like you're a [__] dick you know what
I mean and but these women are like oh
my God they're about to rip each other's
throats out and their husbands are like
this it's fine it's fine it's fine you
know they're scared like it's fine and
he's huffing and puffing cuz he's come
he had come up that hill so fast you
[__] you piece of [__] and right he's
going off and his wife's going dere D
he's like no and she finally goes
Derek they put everything on his card we
owe him money oh my God and he's like
what she goes we I'm trying to tell you
we owe your brother money I go what oh
y'all owe me right now oh man this
[__] took down the hill he
didn't say [__] everyone up there's like
oh my [__] God I'm like that's just
totally that's typical like so then he
knows he knows he's got to come back up
and eat [__] Crow and he see him
about 30 minutes later just slow ass
walking up that mountain and he gets to
the top and he's got to make the most
humbling embarrassing apology he's I
would do it during a
toast I like to raise my glass but
before we get to the bride and groom I
just want to
say this [__] is trying to
apologize not to me only but to everyone
for the se's cause it's so great but
he's so out of breath and he's got cot
mouth he's like I just want I just want
to say like like this and and he's like
can I get a drink and I go no anyone
gets up and gets him a [__] drink is
going to have to deal with me he doesn't
get a [__] drink finish saying what
you're GNA say and he is just like just
want to say I'm sorry like he had to
apologize like that so great the whole
place I think everybody should have
lined up and just going gut her head and
then take a shot at him just gut her
head let's go like that nonstop just
everything I remember my cousin's wife
going you argue just like your cousin I
go what do you mean she's like well
right away it's like listen [__] you
know anybody else is normal is like yeah
man what I'm not listening to anything
like what what's the matter with
that dude tell me about um growing up
cuz I do know I've had Tony hinchcliff
on who I believe was also young Italian
mafia style Youngtown Ohio little [__]
Youngstown was a big mob town like in
the 50s and 60s there's nothing there
now I don't think but uh was it a an
original Mobtown or was it like that's
where a lot of guys relocated once [__]
got no I think an original mob town I
think it was just cuz the steel industry
and unions and uh just was wild back
then you watch documentaries about it
they used to blow each other up which is
not something they did in New York too
much it's more of like a sicilian thing
car bombs but in Youngstown they would
do it all the time they blow fighting
over mostly gambling operations I think
lone sharking but it's all gone now but
um and what did your parents do growing
up what do they work in young my father
was a mushroom farm
and canning operation my my grandfather
lived on the they lived on the east side
of the Youngstown when my father was
growing up and I'm talking about regular
mushrooms though right now yeah regular
mushrooms yeah yeah mushroom and what
else mushroom growing and canning
operation so he had a convenience store
he had a convenience store in Youngstown
my grandfather growing up Frankie's
prepared
foods um shit's prepared
man
tagline ready for whatever yeah so he
has this this this and then he wanted to
get into canning spaghetti sauce but uh
that's when Ragu came in like Ragu came
in and and took over the market so he
had to Pivot so instead of spaghetti
sauce he started canning mushrooms and
then it became successful and he's like
why am I buying all these mushrooms I'll
just I have land out here I'll buy the
land I'll build a growing operation and
then grow and can the mushrooms
so that's the that's when I came up
that's what we were doing that's and
it's mushrooms grow indoors so you were
you you know a little bit about grown
mushrooms very little I know very little
about it but you were around this as a
kid no [__] all right I've never have
you ever met anyone else that's ever
even done that uh there's like Italians
in uh Pennsylvania who also have a
mushroom farm um I think their name is
shrai I'm not sure but it's like Kenneth
Square area like those are like the
competing mushroom Farms but I think I
mean I think there's there's still
mushroom farms in kennet square but uh
most of the market is uh Chinese
mushroom like um Asian so was that was
passed on to your father no what
happened was my grandfather and my
father and my aunt and my uncle were all
in the business together and my father
and
grandfather uh couldn't get along my
grandfather was a tough guy to deal with
he was old school Italian you know uh
from he was born here but they had come
over whole story his father was a
musician he died at an early age it was
him and the and his mother didn't speak
any English so he had three brothers and
sisters and had to like uh just drop out
of eighth grade and get a job eighth
grade yeah so he had to figure it out
and um you know by polar disorder that
my my great-grandmother had bipolar
disorder and as a result my grandfather
had it so he's dealing with that and
then there's no safety net at that time
so if like you don't work and you don't
make money then just everybody starves
so it was uh I'm sure a wild time just
from the stories that I've heard it was
it was absolutely wild so he had that
like kind of chip on his shoulder like
build it from the ground up type you
know there was no free lunch for me
there shouldn't be a free lunch for
anyone type uh thing so and he was hard
he was a hard guy and my father just
wanted love and approval and and and
never got it from him you know until the
very very end so um yeah so as a result
they were trying to work in the business
together and it blew up and in 1981 we
moved to boa rone Florida that's that's
very bro it's Bo my father was basically
like I just don't want to be here
anymore it's cold we had no ties to
Florida it was just like I'm out I'm
going to the the most beautiful place
and my father hated the cold weather he
hated icy roads he hated the like
everything about it you know how your
emotions it just gets morphed into one
thing he hated the the relationship and
working for his father and the way he
was treated and he morphed all of that
somehow into the weather and it's like
he was like I'm just going to the most
beautiful place and I just want to be
out of here picked this up and we moved
to batone Florida and how old were you
at that point I was uh nine okay so you
definitely remember that yeah I I
remember that because in in Ohio we had
a little bit of money because we're in a
family business we lived in a big house
like you know and then when we moved I
could see the drop even though we moved
Boer Ron is known as a wealthy place we
went back to like we don't have anything
you know yeah yeah we lived on the we
lived on the um Del Beach border and uh
and I remember not I
remember being like oh we don't have M
we we couldn't turn the air conditioning
on we couldn't pay the air conditioning
and it was you know we're from Ohio and
it's Florida it's a Florida summer so I
remember the ceiling fans and I remember
going into the bathroom and splashing
cold water on my face and then keeping
the ceiling fan on in order to go to
sleep at night so it's like you would
think Boone money but we went the
opposite way you know how did you get to
Florida drive we drove what did you
drive I I don't remember the car we we
had a we had I remember we we had uh a
bunch of Cs cuz they kept breaking down
we were buying AER American car they
were breaking down that's like early '
80s at the time and uh so we bought a
Toyota van oh yeah and everybody just um
[__] on us for buying a toy they're like
you're buying a Japanese carer this is
America and stuff and it's like it's
like hey dude we want to we can't have
the car we don't have any money like the
car can't be in the shop every two weeks
and I remember that Toyota van we put
like 150,000 miles on it it was
unbelievable do whatever the [__] you
want it was so good so we drove down and
that sometimes we didn't like I remember
we didn't have the money to stay in
hotels sometimes so we' we'd pull over
to rest stop and just sleep you know and
I remember I remember just like being in
the pass I remember sleeping in the
driver's side like sleeping and uh being
mad that we didn't get to go to a hotel
and having to sleep in the car and uh I
remember being mad and then my father
said he you were mad and then just
passed out like on him he was in the he
was in the passenger side but it was all
good it was all good and how long do you
stay in bokeh I stayed there until we
were until I was uh 13 so four years
yeah and then we moved I I did uh third
fourth fifth 6th seventh grade okay so
you made some friends down there thir
third through 7th you're playing sports
and all that like really getting in the
community and stuff yeah well I played
uh uh football uh contact football and
that's why people are like you can't
have kids play contact football and I go
I get it man I get the science and I get
it but I have to say there's something
about playing a contact sport that is at
a young age that's different than
playing a non-con sport it builds like
tenacity and grit and there's something
mentally that you have to prepare for
when you go into a contact sport at a
young age you have to mentally prepare
yourself there so much going on cuz if
it's just a Skills game you don't have
to mentally prepare ain't going to
[__] the way that you do when you go
even I remember let's play checkers
while we punch each other in the face
yeah there's something about you have to
mentally prepare for that contact for
that impact and I remember at 9 years
old like going to not wanting to go to
practice and having to suck it up and go
to practice because we never were able
to quit anything mid year so um going to
practice and having to mentally save
energy during the day and mentally
prepare myself for what was going to
happen at practice and it's like drills
the Oklahoma drills like that kind of
stuff it's like you know and now I I
went back to my high school years ago
and um and they don't practice in pads
during the week is that right yeah
because they were like it's too many
injuries and I understand it but I was
like this would have changed my whole
High School experience not playing in
pads during the week we hit during the
week we hit during the week and like I
said like in high school whatever You'
you go to school and be like I got
practice tonight so I I gotta I can't
expend too much energy because I have to
mentally prepare myself for the contact
that's coming you know and I wrestled
also late that was later on and that was
the sport for me too like I played
everything I played soccer football
baseball basketball lacrosse all my high
school I didn't play football I played
soccer they wouldn't let me double up
but uh baseball but um wrestling was the
one where like of anything in my life
I've been able to exert my anger my
frustration right um and it's the one
sport where like that's the one where if
you cheat your you're only cheating
yourself that's that's the one there no
behind you oh that ball got tipped I
caught it that you missed that ground
ball I got it yeah I love the
camaraderie of football but wrestling is
really who you you find out who you are
you find out who you are that's right so
I love not you as a teammate you as an
individual and what your strong your
strengths are what your weaknesses are
and I was not the best athlete I was not
the best athlete good wrestler you got a
wrestler's body yeah I was good for my
area or whatever but I there was guys I
wrestled with throughout the year who
were I mean just crazy talented and
those guys like especially in college I
went to Penn State I wrestled for a year
at State no [__] you you're good then
that's well no I was good for my area
and I I went to Penn State and um look
you don't get to a D1 school and not and
play a sport and not be good well the
thing is is is enduring that that year I
mean it was the training I Florida
wasn't known as a good wrestling State
Ohio Pennsylvania those guys coming from
those States still a big jump to go to
that program that Penn State program
which is UN phenomenal now but even when
I we were like third in the country with
the year I wrestled so it was very tough
all Americans all up and down the lineup
but um yeah it's you could be good for
your I was good in my I placed in States
in Florida I placed I went to the finals
and placed second and then um when I
went to P it was just such a shock such
a culture shock it's like I mean every I
I pride of myself on working hard in
higho school but it and when you go to
college like everybody works hard
everybody works everybody puts in a
massive like everybody does 10 times
what you did in high school right and
these are guys who are super talented
and uh a lot of the super talented guys
I think about this sometimes like I had
my own experience with wrestling with
the physical capabilities that I had but
some of the guys who were super talented
they had a different experience I think
not that they didn't work hard but I
think things just came easier to those
guys and that's a good thing for them in
that moment but it's it's a different
thing in terms of like looking back uh
as and learning life lessons from it
like you know I had a lot of adversity
when I wrestled like losing I would get
pinned I was wrestling varsity as a
sophomore and I would get pinned in
Florida I would get pinned in being
pinned in an auditorium full of people
is uh crazy you know what I mean it's
like humiliating so I mean out there we
when in high school we had a really good
wrestling culture like they would put us
in the main gym where at basketball this
is Colorado this is Maryland oh Maryland
just High School too and it was mats
that covered the whole [__] gym yeah
and one Circle in the middle just like
Vision Quest and we had the BT that
would come down they would turn all the
lights off in the gym and you would you
you would get humiliated under the
[__] Spotlight while the gym is H
that's great I'll do you one better we
had that Spotlight and they would have
in Florida they would have in school
matches so they would let they would do
like an assembly where they let all the
kids into the match seventh period and
you would wrestle in front of the entire
School while school was in session so
you get pinned in one of those it's like
you're just hearing math class
later even your teachers are like hey
what's going on why all about man yeah
that's great but I also Imagine That
sport I know what it did I know what my
backstory is and I know what wrestling
did for me as a person it also helped me
be able to be like okay I can take a
[__] headbutt to the face I can get
punched I can get you know banged up I
can but I also can hang out here
somebody in my weight class I'm all
right you know I can handle myself but I
imagine bouncing from CU you said you
went from Youngstown to Florida right
then you went back to Youngstown then
you went back to Florida back to Florida
your D your dad and grandfa and make it
up and break it up well yes basically
that's what it was that's what it was so
so we go to Florida and then um my
father has a couple businesses that fail
and um and then so he just is without a
job and uh so my grandfather comes down
his business is not doing well because
my my father was good at the business
and and really put his heart and soul
into it wanted to get that approval from
his father so um my grandfather comes
down humbles himself comes down asks my
father to come back my father goes goes
I need a contract I need it in writing
like I can't this emotional roller
coaster cuz my grandfa was dealing with
his own mental health issues which were
not known about back then so he signs a
contract and we move back and when we
moved back we moved to a town where my
mother is from which is a small town
it's such a small town my mother's
family is the first Italians in the town
no way yeah it's great it's really
classic first Italians in the town and
uh and I went I got to like walk to
school in Florida I walk to school I
walk to school I could you know I really
loved being there and it was for two
years and that's where I learned to
wrestle eth and nth grade and the
programs were really good in Ohio and
then we moved and then you know things
went sideways again my grandfather like
screamed at my bed threw a cup of coffee
in his face and my father's like we're
we're out of here we're out of here so
back to bokeh baby back to B so we went
back to boa and U but you're also now
going back to a community where you know
people I know people but I I went to
different I went to different schools I
went to a different middle school so I
was I was going to a different high
school I went to a high school in
another Middle School in another town
and then I went to high school in in
Boke I went to Boke rone Community High
School and I got to say both places were
unbelievable I have friends to this day
from both you do places yeah I really I
mean Ohio was great friends and great a
great group of people and Florida was
the same so I loved uh I loved the both
yeah and uh but wrestling is is it
really for me you bouncing around and
just being able to know you can handle
yourself out there and well the thing is
now when I look back at the wrestling
because the business we're in you know
it's like you're up you're down this
could be an opportunity maybe not
there's money coming here there's no
money for a while it's like tumultuous
whatever so that's always in the back of
my mind to be like oh I cut weight I cut
a lot of weight
and and that does something mentally to
you too it's like if I can do that I can
be in a gutter and figure it out like I
can be in a gutter and and be able to
figure it out because of the experiences
that I had during wrestling so that's
what it gives you it gives you the
self-discipline is unbelievable and also
I learned stuff um you know the mental
toughness that it takes you know to even
get through a practice forget a matches
and competing and all that stuff like
the practices were brutal I thought the
first uh couple times wrestling going to
a wrestling practice I thought we were
being punished I thought the whole
practice was a punishment I was like
what did we do wrong does this guy hate
because we came from football it's like
this does this coach hate football
players no no no this is what it is so
it was on another level of difficulty
yeah which I I actually grew to like you
know that not everybody could do it and
I don't know if it's happening now or
happened where you came from but there
was a real rivalry between basketball
and wrestling and cuz all of the Blue
Chip uh the glory sport was basketball
so during the winter all the kids who
would go out for basketball and then
they would get cut and then the
wrestling coaches would be like why
don't you guys we don't cut anybody come
come over here come over here and we
would get some guys who ended up being
very successful at wrestling because
they got cut from basketball and there
was always that rivalry like um even in
college I remember uh when I was at Penn
State we would go through a um you'd
have to schedule uh a training session
with in the waight room it's half hour
and they do is they they take you
through stations it's a half hour uh
course and what you do is you get on
like the lat pull down and you doom to
exhaustion and then when you can't do he
helps you with two and then they pull
the pin and they go two or three lighter
and then you do as many as you can from
there and they get let you do two or
three to exhaustion and they pull the
pin again and then you do a couple more
till you can't get any and then that's
one exercise and then you move to the
next one and that by the time you got
through it at the at the beginning of it
you would be throwing up on the second
or third exercise but by the time you
you would get used to it and get through
it and that's another thing you have to
mentally prepare yourself to go through
that because you know you're going to
suffer the whole point is to suffer
suffer through it and to mentally
callous your mind in order to get
through it so
uh just going there and do it I remember
going with the trainer and uh after like
the second ex he goes do you want water
I go dude let's just go let's go and he
goes you guys are so much because they
would do it with the basketball team too
he goes you guys are so much more
mentally tough than the basketball
players he's like There He Go you guys
cuz I could tell like I said something
that everybody else all the other
wrestlers said like let's just go dude
let's go and he goes oh my God you guys
are the best they loved us you know what
I mean but um yeah it was a different it
was basketball was the glory sport
wrestling was the sport that was gritty
we were gritty your dad supportive of
all that stuff he was supportive of it
he didn't know anything much about the
sport but I loved it because he was so
involved in football and uh like that
wrestling was my thing that he didn't
really understand and I learned on my
own so it was like my own little
personal thing yeah so I love that um
yeah me too that's great you say it that
way because I'm thinking about it now
yeah but the life lessons I mean I can't
stress enough like the life lessons from
wrestling it's just it's it it pays off
monumentally in your life so when you're
especially in your life when you're
going through adversity and tough times
and girls break up with you and you're
you have no money it's like you still
have that thing in the back of your mind
where it's like oh I endured this level
of suffering before there's no reason I
can't endure this and figure it out and
come out on top it's really really huge
one thing I wanted to ask you about cuz
I remember this from your special and um
we just talked about your dad but your
dad passed not too long ago right yeah
um and what
happened well we would we had a
tumultuous relationship because you did
you and your dad yeah we did we did it
we he was always very loving so he was
very emotional with me and very loving
cuz I think it was because his father he
wanted this approval from his father and
never got it so he made a conscious
decision to be like I'm not going to be
that way with my kids I'm going to be
openly loving to the point of like he
was like super emotional with us so he
was that way and he was very involved in
all of our activities and supportive he
would coach teams and do all that stuff
and but he was he was tumultuous he had
his own issues so he was tumultuous but
I knew I was loved and everything and
then I think what happened when I was 18
when I was in college um my grandfather
passed and they made peace on my
grandfather's deathbed did they they
made peace yeah were you there to see
that I wasn't there to see it it was in
Ohio was in Florida did you ever told
your dad about it yeah he said he he he
basically said that they made peace yeah
he my grandfather was sick and my father
ended up taking care of him and in that
taking care like taking him in the
shower washing him all that stuff it's
like it it really um they they made
peace
and uh can I ask you this did their
fractured relationship ever affect your
relationship with your grandfather Yeah
it it actually did because when we were
leaving the second to come back for the
second time I was
13 so I knew what was happening and my
grandfather pulled me aside which is
very unlike him and tried to explain to
me that it wasn't his fault that my
father had a hard head and he doesn't
listen and and I I just was I didn't
have the
skill set or the emotional intelligence
to call him out and be like hey what
you're doing is like if it was now or
something or when I was an adult I would
be like hey you have to show him love he
obviously starving for affection here he
just wants your approval it's there's no
cost involved in you putting your arms
around him well I'm not built that way
it's like you you figure it out like it
just he's looking for that this all
could be avoided this whole thing could
be avoided if you would just give him
approval and just put your arms around
him I mean just tell him you love him I
it's it's crazy how this isn't that
crazy how that something that simple
could solve so many things yeah just a
hug and I love you and thank it wasn't
he was just so like it's not in my
wheelhouse to do this right but I I
didn't have the emotional intelligence
at the time or the um wasn't articulant
enough to say that or frankly didn't
have the balls because I was intimidated
he was an intimidating guy to do that
and uh and I was just like okay you know
it's I'm I was cuz I was upset about
having to leave all my friends and leave
all the programs I was involved with in
Ohio and family to go back to Florida
which I didn't really want to go back
did you know that traditional
anti-depressants only work for about 40
to 60% of people they can also come with
heavy side effects make you feel numb
and they might require taking a daily
pill for the rest of your life we need
more and better Alternatives there's no
quick fix for anxiety and depression but
there could be something to unlock your
brain a new way of thinking about and
seeing the world maybe that thing is
guided ketamine therapy from mind Bloom
there's a new tool to improve your
mental health atome ketamine therapy
mind Bloom is the leader in atome
ketamine therapy having safely help
thousands of people overcome their
anxiety and depression unlike
traditional talk therapy ketamine Works
quickly and doesn't have the unpleasant
side effects of traditional
anti-depressants in a study of over
1,200 mind Bloom clients 89% reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only four sessions
right now my mind Bloom is offering my
listeners $100 off your first six
session program when you sign up at mind
bloom.com honeydo and use promo code
honeydew take the first step and break
free from your anxiety and depression
with mind Bloom mind bloom.com honeydo
and use promo code honeydew now let's
get back to the D so um what happened
with you and your dad so when my
grandfather when my grandfather
died weird shift happened where my
father kind of quickly forgot how much
he hated the way he was treated and then
kind of like took that mantle uh as the
patriarch of the family and started
weirdly kind of like doing the things to
some extent that my grandfather did
where being like hard on issues where he
was never hard before and not being his
understanding as he was when I was
growing up because it was right in his
face he he he hated it so much uh from
his father so
um we had problems because I would go
home to
visit and it would start very loving it
would always be it would be a pattern it
would start very loving for a couple of
days I miss you I love you blah blah
blah and then after about two days
things I feel the tension start to build
and then something would happen and he
would just explode and we'd be in a huge
fight and that would happen and then
that took place for a couple days and
then right before I left we would make
up and everything would be fine again
and it that pattern kind of happened
every time I went home to the point
where my sister was like stop coming
home like stop coming home it's like
triggering something in him and and and
it's never Pleasant and it it almost was
like you're pulled in different
directions because I was like I love my
father and respect with Italians I'm
sure you know is like a big thing it's
like and anytime anything would get uh
tumultuous he'd be like I'm your father
you respect me I'm your father it's like
yeah it works both ways you can't just
I'm not a punching bag either you can't
just explode on say anything to me yeah
it's like it's like that's not the way
you treat someone you love I know all
this now but back then I didn't I just
know knew I didn't like what was
happening so I'm like and and also I was
like why does it have to be this way why
it's it's we're making it hard for no
reason it to one point we got into a
fight and he was like we're making up I
go I I have to come in and stay in a
hotel like I can't stay here he goes
Mike that would break my heart I go it
break your heart it's going to it's
driving me crazy it's literally driving
me crazy what what what we're doing here
none of this is necessary none of it I I
don't know what we're doing and um he'd
be like Mike we got to go through this
I'm like we don't have to go through
this at all this is
all crazy you know he didn't he was just
in this mind you know we live out our
patterns you know our mind patterns the
way he was raised what he thought was
love that's what he thought was love and
he just goes instead of like pulling
back from it and go oh this this doesn't
have to be this way the presence of mine
like he just kept running on that
pattern and after a while I just had to
be
like there was no way to deal with it
other than just let him abuse let him
let him abuse me or fight back and then
it was going to be on so I chose the
second thing I chose I was like let's
just let it just be on then
you know so how long was that that was a
good period of uh I would say 18 19
years old till I was 40 oh [__] yeah
that would happen talking about a couple
decades oh man but but in between it's
like I love you know love and emo but
but then when it would go south it would
just you know he was it was tumultuous
see in every relationship I think that
there's like somebody who's tumultuous
and then somebody who's like an anchor
my mother was like an anchor school
teacher 40 plus years just kept the
family together solid logical my father
was emotional tumultuous great I mean
people loved him
personality um had sales jobs people
love he would sell great because of his
personality and people loved him but he
was just he was tumultuous at times you
know but I the thing the good thing
about my child I always knew I was loved
I always knew I was loved and supported
we went through our we went through it
you know obviously but I always knew
that I was and my father would made no
bones about showing love and affection
and emotion and like kissing us telling
us he loved us there was never any of
those issues so I'm I'm grateful for
that everybody gets it different you
know what I mean I I think so I was
really fortunate to have that so that 20
years goes by and what happens what
makes you finally um reconcile we get
into a huge a really big fight and I how
old are you0 at this
point0 [__] man and and we get into a
really really big fight I can't get go
into what it's over but it's a really
big one and I felt really angry that he
came at me in this certain kind of way
over this this issue and uh I said I
just said I'm not talking to you again
I'm not I don't deserve this this is
crazy I'm I'm I had it I'm not talking
to you again it's and I told my m cuz my
mother was
supporting they still together at the
time so supporting his position I said
I'm not talking to either of you so
eight months I didn't talk to them which
is crazy in my family is that yeah eight
months eight months I was like not
talking not talking to either would they
call and stuff yeah my mom call my mom
will call my mom will call and my mom's
like I don't care what you say I'm still
calling you I go I'm not talking to
either of you what you did was wrong and
have the presence of mind to know that
you're wrong and apologize and if you
apologize I'll forgive you that's that's
all I care about too a thoughtful
meaningful apology just sucks all my
thunder and lightning right out of me
I'm like all right all right yeah
apologize for I mean I there's no secret
I love you I'm so I love you you know
what I mean it's just like I I don't
understand like you you he couldn't I I
was like I misjudged I thought you were
a different guy like back in the days
growing up he would have done I think he
would have done that but after my
grandfather died think he just became
harder and was like now you're you're
the son now you're the son now now you
eat it I'm the father now it's like yeah
let's stop all this this is this is a
CRA you didn't like it you hated it and
now you're becoming that like what are
we doing right but I I guess he felt
like now I'm the father and you're the
son now you eat it and
you so what after the eight months
happens where you I'm assuming you took
your mom's call probably no no we're
back in Young down we go back in youngst
I'm still not talking to him we get
together as a family event which is
awkward cuz we're not talking and this
is the first time for anything like this
right first time like seeing them so uh
we go to the bar we're at the event we
go to the bar we start talking and he
goes if you
wanna uh if you want to start talking
again we
can and I go I want an apology he he
would not apologize but he did say
something that soften me he goes
look if you had my
life he if you had my life you would be
dead or in jail right now if you would
had the life I had you know with my
parents the way that I came up you would
be dead or in jail and I I didn't look
at that as a slate I look I I kind of
understood that he's already playing
over his head like he's doing the best
he can he's playing way over his
basically that's what he was saying I'm
playing way over my head already you
expect me to be at this level where I
can see things and be the father you
want me to be I'm already doing more
than I possibly ever thought I could be
doing so that softened me to the point
where it's like he he he's just doing
the best that he can so I I let up a
little bit and then we started talking
again and then he said afterward he
didn't apologize but he said the fight
that Happ that'll never happen again I
guarantee it'll never happen again so
that's a thing where it's like he
he took responsibilities like he knew he
was wrong it'll never Happ yeah it'll
never happen again it didn't listen I'm
going start using
that that thing didn't happen it'll
never Happ it never happened again so
when he did that it it did it soften me
and and and I tell people that sometimes
and they go how does he know they take
it like oh he was trying to it was a
slight I didn't think it was a slight I
thought it was him basically saying I'm
doing the best that I possibly can dude
I feel your dad so hard on that man man
I feel like I come from no parents at 16
on and I just feel like I'm I'm a I'm a
[__] twin because of birth or um
fertility pills I just feel like I'm on
house money wow you know what I mean
were you born first or was your brother
he was I'm the second one I'm the
smallest of ever my mom's six foot bro
he was your opener he was my opener bro
headliner goes second you know how it
goes you know how it goes you go ahead
out there first I'm I'm going chill in
here for 4 minutes warm them up then I'm
make my appear That's great um but yeah
I just I feel the same way like I know
there's a lot of things people want from
me sometimes and I'm like I I just don't
compute like I under I I want you to
know that I understand that you're
presenting this math word problem to me
right I don't know how to [__] do
that right I don't even mean to be a
dick about it or I just want you to know
my skill set doesn't involve what you're
asking of me and I feel that same way
like I can't believe how far I've come
going to EMDR therapies and talk
therapies and
journaling I mean what I'm doing a lot
and I'm doing so much that I'm like I I
don't know if I have the capacity for
more I don't want to be an ignorant
person or or hurt anyone but there's
only so much I have right you know and
and we're better than our parents were
oh my God you know and the hope is that
your kids are you know boom and a boom
and a boom smarter better faster
stronger quicker you know but the
therapy and all that stuff like I went
through a bad breakup when I was in my
uh late 20s and looking back on it I was
like oh I should have went to therapy
then but therapy
wasn't I didn't think a therapy the same
way your dad never went to therapy never
went to therapy but he went to a he did
go to a
therapist uh cuz my sister is a
therapist and she got him to go to a
therapist after our fight and therapist
told him he was wrong and he didn't want
to hear it like [__] hear is that right
yeah he fired the therapist on the
spot no but it's like in fames like
yoube to surface on anybody's family
it's like there's all of this there's
all of this involved and I I got to say
of all of that I got a great deal I got
a great deal CU I was loved and
supported and my whole like childhood
and I knew it and there's something this
is I maybe an Italian thing I have
friends who are Italian whose fathers
don't tell them they love them they
don't hug them and I had a friend um I
got into his car and uh I I was talking
to my father and I said okay I Love You
by he who was that he I go that's my
father he goes you say you love you I
love you to your father I go yeah and he
goes I would never do that with my
father and I go you gotta do it you got
Life's Too Short Man Life's Too Short
you got to do it and there there's some
people who don't I'm like just do it I
don't care if it's uncomfortable I don't
care if it's uncomfortable you got to do
it but I I fortunately I always had that
was it more difficult not to talk to
your mom or your dad during that period
uh I was really mad I was real mad at
both of them so um but it was harder on
my mom because my mom was like a
casualty kind of of it she was still at
fault but I look at it her like casualty
but it's like ni my mom my mom's a real
standby your man type and I respected
her for that but at the same time it's
like the mafia wife yeah tell him he's
wrong
we don't know what you're talking about
but I apply pressure I apply pressure is
like talk to your guy you want to talk
to me talk to your guy talk to your guy
your guy did was wrong what he did was
wrong talk to
[Music]
him so then what happens to your dad you
say then after that he starts to get
sick what kind what happened what kind
of he had a respiratory illness is
before covid was he a smoker or anything
back in the day cigars cigarettes back
in the day but he quit once you know he
was in his 40s I think they he quit and
then and then cigar he had an obsessive
personality like if he bought a dog he
would have to buy two dogs and a parrot
remember we went on a vacation one time
my mother leaves we all and come back
and there's two dogs on a parrot my
mother's ah should have left this guy
alone you know he was he he had an
obsessive and he got obsessive with uh
cigars he started smoking like four or
five a day and it's like how do you
think this is going to it's not going to
end well you know so uh how old was he
75 but at 75 like the doctor is a family
friend of ours and uh the doctor pulled
my mother aside and when he he didn't
have that long he was telling her he's
like be realistic he only has a couple
months here and uh my mother's like all
right just tell your family so everybody
knows and uh so your mom broke that news
to you my mom broke it to me yeah yeah
that he didn't have that long so uh but
but the doctor did say to my mother you
you kept him alive this long my mother
kept him my mom on top of everything
medication like my mom was on top of
everything so uh and taking care of him
she goes and and he was a family friend
the doctor so he he knew he's like he
doesn't last this long if it's not for
you so my mother kept him alive for I
would say a couple years of just like
dam being doctor point my my father
would have never left to his own devices
it would have been yeah the doctors I
deal with now they tell me like I'm on
blood thinners now and it's twice a day
and they're like look we could give you
the one a day but it's not a great
medication and also we give the One A
Day to the people who forget their
[__] socks you know I was like I
forget the am the type of people these
doctors see where people are just like I
don't know yeah yeah you're dead yeah
yeah so it was that it was uh get to
talk and yeah you know I would I spent
time with him I got to go home and I
would book gigs in in the in Florida and
I would go home I would do the gig and
then I would come back and I in you know
I would just like hang out with them and
boxing is something that we bonded over
I never boxed I but he was into it he
was really into box so I started getting
into boxing and that's something we
would watch the fights and um when I was
in New York at the Garden like I got
tickets to a big fight and brought him
up and he went to a big fight and and uh
it's something we bonded over so was it
the best you've ever gotten along it was
good it was good he was in pain but it
was nothing but it was like nothing but
love and we you know I I don't want the
whole childhood I wanted we we had spots
where everything was good and you know
we got along but then it was tumultuous
here tumultuous there it it would change
but um but yeah in the end like I would
lay with them in bed and I would uh it
was I'm glad I did it I'm glad I went
down there and spent those that time
because you know at his funeral and and
when he passed I was like um I have no
regrets you and there was nothing left
to say there was nothing you know there
was nothing left to say he said
everything to me I said everything to
him it was it was beautiful was there
anything he said that just still sticks
with you during that time I asked him if
he would have done anything differently
and he said and this really shocked me
cuz he never talked this way before he
goes if I had to do it over again I
would have never given my father that
much power over me wow
yeah never ever said that before
beginning of the trauma right there yeah
he's like instead of realizing like
today you realize oh this is a flawed
man this is a this guy is flawed so I I
can only do so much here I could love
him even from a distance but I can only
do but to give your mind and heart and
soul over to somebody like that it's
like oh he's not a bad guy he's just a
flawed guy so I can't give my mental
stability and my everything o I got my
own family I got my own life like I
can't give that over to this much of a
flawed guy he's just a man he's flawed
but my father didn't look at like that
he's like this guy's like a god like he
looked at him like this is my idol and
he couldn't get that approval you know
for so long and he spent his life trying
to get it and when he couldn't get it he
would spend time like smoking cigars and
and and ruminating over it I learned
that it's like oh don't ever do that
don't ever do that like deal with it in
the moment when you can and then and and
make any uh changes that you need to
make but don't sit and ruminate over the
past because you're wasting your life
and he did that a lot a lot and he
wasted a lot of like time just
ruminating like what could he have done
different have he would have vivid
dreams about working for his father and
all this stuff it's like yeah that's not
that's not good because you're losing
the present moment you know um how was
your mom after Dad pass did she get
closer to you did she move near you or
no she lives in uh Bon Beach Florida and
uh my mom's real self-sufficient like
she's really like she's still healthy
and takes care of health she's really
healthy she walks an hour every day she
drives she's good uh intellectually like
her mind is real sharp my sister is
really down there and really keeps an
eye on her and uh but man she's
self-sufficient and really like I'm
really proud of her like I'm really
proud of her she's unbelievable she's uh
she taught for 40 years like we'll go
into a grocery store and it'll be
somebody from behind the counter who she
taught who's in elementary school who
recognizes her she's like a small
celebrity in Publix but um in publ yeah
she's a public celebrity but um she's
like steady and and and just like um you
know goes to church goes for walks um
goes to the casino with her girlfriend
like just has her life like in order and
mentally like really she's doing well
and she does well um another thing I
wanted to talk to you about because I
remember again in talking to you before
but you were a special ed teacher yes
what made you want to do that it was
kind of a process because I I went to um
Penn State and I got a criminal justice
degree and at that time I was like oh I
want to be a lawyer because as you know
with Italians I think and with a lot of
like ethnic type it's like you're going
to be somebody we didn't have college
you know my mom went to college to be a
teacher but my father never went to
college never got the opportunity so the
whole narrative is you're going to get
educated and you're going to be somebody
and and to them being somebody was a
doctor or a lawyer those are the two
things that meant wealth and a
professional person that everybody
looked up to doctors and lawyers so I
wasn't too good in the Sciences so they
were like you're going to you know think
about being a lawyer I think you would
be a good lawyer so got a criminal
justice degree and then I um get paid to
argue instead of just arguing what the
[__] about argu over nonsense so I I
applied to a couple law schools I
studied for the elsat and my elsat
scores weren't that high and uh my SATs
were low too but my lsats weren't that
high even though I prepared for it and I
didn't get into the places that I wanted
to go and then I started
thinking if this measures how you're
supposed to think as a lawyer do I
really know what it is to be a lawyer I
know what it is to be called a lawyer
but it's like guys uh in and standup
years ago uh they would be with three
arts and I would be like how's three
Arts they go the best part of being with
three Arts is saying that I'm with three
Arts because they were like lower tier
guys I'm not I'm not crapping on uh
three Arts but they were like lower
tiered guys so they would like be like
that's the best part of it and that's
the same thing with like being a lawyer
it's like saying that you're a lawyer
it's like yeah but what is that really
it's like is it tomw are you arguing in
open court and cross-examining like
that's not really what maybe if you're a
trial lawyer there's some of that but
most of it is like research and and and
and books and you know figuring it out
so I thought oh maybe this is a sign
that I'm not supposed to be doing this
maybe I'm supposed to be doing something
else so I took it as a sign I went to a
summer program I remember it was a
Widner University in Delaware and uh I
go you know if I pass the summer program
then they'll admit you to law school but
if you don't pass then you're out you're
on the bubble so I I did the program and
uh I missed it by like two points damn
and I didn't get in and I go there's my
answer so I got a job working at um
school called Glenn Mills which is for
adjudicated uh boys and uh I started
working there as a counselor and I left
there and then I went to another
behavioral school for two or 3 years and
then I went back at night to get my
Master's and certification education so
I said if I'm going to do this I might
as well teach you know you make decent
money teaching and I I was good at what
I was doing I felt like so I went back
you say special are we talking about
disciplinary what kind of special
emotional and learning problems but the
the U behavioral school was a wild place
to work because it was kids lived on
campus and were thrown out of uh uh
Philadelphia schools and um so they
lived on campus and they were un either
unmanageable by parents or their parents
abandoned them so they were waiting for
an foster care whatever and I worked in
the school and the school was wild
because I was behavioral staff before I
got my certification I would sit in the
hallway and if a teacher came out like
this guys this kid's got to go then you
would go in and there was a whole drama
it's like teacher said you got to go you
got to go and I'm not going nowhere like
you're like Here Comes This [__]
single leg
[__] I I would just approach it
like this I hear you because they would
be like [__] you I ain't going nowhere
I'd go hey I I hear what you're saying
but he says you got to go you gota I
didn't even do anything I I'm like I
hear you I hear you but he says you
gotta go you gotta go he's like look you
put your hands on me I'mma [__] you up I
go look I how old are these kids cuz
you're right no they're they're 14 to 18
and you're in your 20s
or yeah myid 20s mid 20s and I go were
there anyone that you think could have
took you yeah yeah kids were kidss were
I mean I there would have been a problem
there would have been a problem with
some of these kids cuz it's like people
don't understand about restraining they
kind of don't get it it's not a fight
you're not having a fight what you need
to do as two orra restraint is like you
need to overpower the person you need to
overpower them because that's safe it
looks like you're jumping a person but
if you're restraining a person it's like
you have to overpower them to the ground
and secure limbs cuz if you don't do
that then it comes a fight and then it's
dangerous to everybody them you
everybody's in danger so it's like when
people are being restrained in that
video of it it I know what it looks like
it looks like you're jumping somebody
but a proper restraint you have to
overpower them to take them to the
ground so um and it has to be in unison
with other people you know unless it's
like a a smaller person then you can
restrain them yourselves you yourself
but if it's like a bigger person who's
strong it's like you have to come at
with a lot of force and you have to take
them to the ground and
then and then you ease up according to
how much they're struggling see that's
the thing that's the thing that's hard
to judge that's what the police are
having a hard time that's the police
over but I will say that you need
overwhelming Force to bring them down
you can't come half like halfway or
you're also getting 150% of that person
you know what I mean they're bringing
everything they playing by rules they're
playing by no rules no rules no rules
and at all their strength yes so what's
the wildest [__] you ever saw in there I
would get bit you get spit on spit on
that was a did you wear the mask or no
no I would just like you just be like
this out there you'd be on the ground
you'd be one person was up top and back
then it was a basket hold I don't think
that's legal anymore but you don't have
any vest for stabbing now because it's
because it's
um it happens kind of on the spot where
it's like okay this kid needs to leave
he's like I'm not going anywhere and
then the kid might try to walk off it's
like it might have to be done on the
spot you can't let them just like go you
have how many of you are there in this
school there's another there's another
person and then there's there's other
staff there who will help but as far as
taking the lead which is the toughest
thing it's you and another another
person another guy you ever have to deal
with multiple kids at the same time well
that's the thing it's like when you go
in in the classroom and then the kids
know what's happening so I if if they're
like don't touch him don't touch it's
like all right you got to you got to
step back you got to step back now was
like let's clear the space because they
know what's today I'll bet you
everybody's got cell phones doing that
[__] I know I'm I'm sure I mean I don't
know how it would work you're taking
you're taking a kid down you have to
take them down you have to isolate so
but the argument before always kind of
went the same [__] you I ain't going
nowhere it's like ye I wouldn't get into
a battle with them like take it personal
after after I figured out what was going
on I would go no no I hear you but I
have a job to do I got to do my job you
want to help me do my job [__] you [__]
your job I'll [__] you up I like look
I'm being paid to do a job I try to
explain it to him like in a in a very
nonemotional way it's like I'm being
paid to do a job here I got to do a job
I don't get paid I get fired and and and
it's like sometimes that would resonate
and sometimes it wouldn't and then I
would watch other staff deal with it
some staff would just come at them real
hard like do what you're told or I'm and
then some staff would Pander to them and
be like come on come on dog you know
it's like it's it's like the I don't
know my way was to just come at it in a
very non-emotional like we got to go we
got to go and then and then if we got to
go to the ground we go to the ground so
we go to but the threats were pretty uh
how often do you get to the ground oh we
do every day every day every because
changing classes and all kinds of like
person going going the whole point yeah
yeah the whole point is like you got to
go to you got to go to back then it was
time out I don't know what they do now
but it you got to go to timeout room to
supposedly calm down reflect on what you
did which it just turned into a
nightmare in there then but at least it
wasn't like you could keep the classes
isolated yeah you could keep the classes
moving and uh and so that was it but the
restraints were like yeah they were they
were rough because you I was making like
no money to do it like very low money
also it's a physical job if you're
having to literally go out there and
Tackle yeah and AGG not a football again
footb tackle you're hitting a guy plays
over everybody's getting up all B this
is the best of this [__] who
doesn't want to go any I almost had an
eye taken out cuz a girl didn't uh a
girl it was by a girl by a girl because
somebody didn't secure a limb so it's
like you got to be on the same page
something or she trying to just just
across my face just quick across my face
and it cut my it cut my face but it
missed my eye thank God but um yeah it's
a it's it's gritty and then there would
be therapists on staff so they get a
timeout and then they would curse a
therapist out and the worst is like they
would have home passes on the weekends
and sometimes the parents would flake
and just be like I'm not picking the kid
up you know and uh and then the
therapists would have to go in and tell
them it's like 5:00 on a Friday
therapist I'm I'm getting ready to get
out of there get ready for my weekend
the therapist comes by and goes look I
got to tell so and so that that that
their home pass is pulled I'm like come
on dude they go I'll do it but but could
you just be in there with me I'm like
all right so I would go in there and and
they would be like your mom stop picking
you up and then they leave they would
leave and then they and then I would I
would sit there until 7 but it was uh
but it was I mean it was a wild it was a
wild experience dealing with those kinds
of kids and but you know after a while I
went it was a it was uh I went back at
night and got my masters and then once I
started teaching in a public school I
would go back to that program during the
Summers and I started instituting my own
program like what are these kids
interested in they're interested in the
criminal justice system because many of
them have relatives and some of them
have been through the justice system so
I started doing a like a like what I
learned in college like a criminal
justice class because it's kind of
interesting you're dealing with gangs
you're talking about the legal system
you're talking about first degree crimes
what's a felony what's a misdemeanor and
you can teach English and teach the
other subjects through that because
they're interested they're interested in
that so I started doing that and then
ended up working really well and I would
have a reward system like we that was
during like the Stone Cold Steve Austin
I I would like tape wrestling on a VHS
and if they were good if we had a good
week and everybody got their points then
we would watch wrestling together would
they love that they loved wrestling
stone cold man that the thing the glass
would break and they would be like
that's Stone Cold and uh so we would do
that we would uh and then when I was
teaching in a public school too I would
do a reward system and um
if uh everybody who qualified for it i'
buy them pizza and there was a I lived
Above This
Italian uh Deli and I would just buy a
bunch of food and then we we'd eat like
kings on on Friday if everybody did the
right thing what would you say you took
away from that mostly what what impacted
you
most
um what's the it was it was it was from
my perspective it was like a a a
different it was it's like wow we're
all I don't know the these kids had a
lot of uh because the therapists would
come in and read their background and
their backgrounds would make you cry
it's like kids locked up in a basement
fed dog food it's just terrible terrible
things you know so um you were dealing
with the manifestation of those Behavior
you those behaviors of how these kids
were they didn't come into the world I
don't know if you're like this but have
you ever see a person who's like on the
Street and they're like going through
withdrawal or whatever it's like that
person was a baby at one time so imagine
the things they had to go through to get
to that point right you know so I look
at it from in in a sense of compassion
from that perspective now that being
said I think that the way that
compassionate people deal with it is
mostly from what I've seen wrong it's
like those people having
those having those experiences they need
even more structure and they need even
more of a tight program and discipline
so that they have a chance to live like
a good life you know so I mean
compassion comes after like discipline
and all of this other stuff in play
that's the most compassionate thing you
can do is have a good organized program
and giving them the best chance to
succeed just giving them what they want
and letting letting them off the hook
and and because you feel bad for them is
it's instinctively the thing you want to
do but it's the wrong thing to do that's
what I've learned it's like it's like
show love and compassion through the
discipline it's the most important very
well said yeah um dude this has been a
great episode I told you before we
recorded that I was going to ask you
advice and I'm curious what you're going
to say cuz I'm you're bouncing around
quite a bit what's you said you were
going to call me a [__] on the air and
you still haven't done it
yet I appreciate you waiting to the end
to say that though he said you promised
me ethnic slur I did yeah um advice you
would give to your 16-year-old
self um everything we talked about you
going bouncing back and forth your dad
your grandfather what would you tell
16year old I would say
uh stay focused and be resilient because
I was a very sensitive kid and I would
get hurt you know whether it's losing
and getting pend in wrestling or and and
and and I would have a hard time
recovering from that but it's like it's
okay little compassionate selft talk and
stay the course like stay the course and
um you know be resilient don't let that
sensitivity overtake you because I think
a lot of kids are like that they're
sensitive kids it's like it's good to be
that way it really is I think it's why
we're standup Comics it's why we're in
this field but don't let that throw you
like and I have to remind myself of that
today you know so my 16-year-old self I
definitely would have been like stay the
course be resilient
positive selft talk that's great yeah
that's great dude um thank you man
please plug promote everything again
comic mikev on all social media
platforms please follow me at Comic
mikev because I I'm touring and I'm uh I
I have a really good hour it's called
the attractives on YouTube please watch
it uh Mike von.com for dates um comic
mikev on all social media platforms and
please watch my podcast it's uh Mike
veon investigates it's available on
iTunes so uh I I can't thank you enough
for having me on I appreciate I called
you and I I mean I texted you you you
you when you were in New York you were
like hey when you come out let me know
and I texted you and sure enough you
gave me a date immediately so I really
appreciate that so thank you so much
look man I love comedians uh you're a
great dude so thanks for doing it um and
as always Ryan sichler on all social
media go watch my special Lefty son get
your tickets at ryan.com we'll talk to
you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]